hello in this video we'll talk about
cholecystokinin so cholecystokinin is a
hormone
which is important for gastric function
in this video we would talk about what
is cck
or cholecystokinin what is the function
of it and what is the molecular
mechanism of
its action and lastly we would summarize
all this video so stay tuned till the
end of this video it would be a very
short
but comprehensive video so
cholecystokinin
is composed of varying number of amino
acids it's the amino acid type hormone
and it is modified from a precursor
known as pre-pro cholecystokinin which
is
150 amino acid long from that
there could be different variants such
as cck58
suggesting 58 amino acid containing
cholecystokinin
cck33 cck22 all of these
uh iso forms or different formats
could be modified by post
translational modification and after
that
it would be very functional and each of
these different variant has different
functions
we would discuss all of that so
cholecystokinin is secreted from the
endocrine cells of duodenum
and some portion of the jejunum
so cck is a peptide hormone
that acts on primarily on pancreatic
acinar cells
also it acts on liver gold brother
and also the stomach and
each case it has a distinct effect
so cck leads to release of all the
digestive enzymes
from the pancreas and when it comes to
gallbladder
it leads to secretion of pile so these
are the two
major functions of cck
now the question is what leads to
cholecystokinin secretion so let us
understand the
reason of cholecystokinin secretion
so whenever food comes from stomach
to the duodenum the acidity of the food
need to be neutralized and also
the food need to be digested so the food
gives a kind of feedback which leads to
cholecystokinin secretion from these
antenna endocrine cells and ultimately
the cholecystokinin
would be acting upon pancreas
gallbladder etc to digest the food for
example
if you have ingested fatty acids
digested partially digested proteins or
amino acid all of these substances
or presence of all of these substances
can increase
cholecystokinin secretion in contrast
carbohydrates such as glucose or any
other carbohydrates can
give rise to a brief increase in cck
levels
but one thing that really increased
cholecystokinin secretion
is the fat
so now let's talk about what is the
effect of
cholecystokinin secretion so what is the
outcome
so once cck is secreted it majorly acts
on the pancreatic cells pancreatic
acinar cells
which lead to secretion of
majority of the pancreatic enzymes such
as pancreatic amylase lipase
trypsinogen gymotrypsinogen etc
now let us look at the pancreas to
understand this phenomena better so
cck travels through the bloodstream and
now it
works on the acinar cells and also the
duct cells
and leads to secretion of
pancreatic enzymes and these enzymes
are really important for digestion and
absorption
for example pancreatic amylase trypsin
chymotrypsin etc and all release
actually 60 to 70 percent release
is modulated by cck only
so cck has a huge role in pancreatic
enzyme secretion so let us look at the
molecular level
so cck is a peptide type hormone so it
binds to cck receptor
generally in the pancreas it is cck
receptor type b
and it stimulates a g protein signaling
cascade which ultimately leads to
calcium elevation in the cytosol
now the elevated calcium helps in
vesicle containing
enzymes fusing
and release of these enzymes into the
acing so that leads to
pancreatic secretion so now we
understand the molecular mechanism of it
so now let's talk about what is the
effect of
cck on bile secretion
so cck is a major hormonal regulator of
gallbladder contraction so gallbladder
contraction can be evoked by
neuronal cues or hormonal cues and the
major hormonal
player is cck so consistent with these
uh effect cck also relaxes the sphincter
of od
and helps to secrete bile
in the duodenum
moreover it has effects on stomach
so cck actually delays the gastric
emptying ensuring when the content of
the stomach is reaching the duodenum
at that point of time all the pancreatic
enzyme should be present so this timing
match
is actually done by cck at a molecular
level
so cck relax the proximal stomach and
also leads to contraction of the pylorus
and that is the major effect of cck
on stomach when it comes when it
talks about a central nervous system cck
receptor can be
found in various parts especially in the
limbic system
so cck mediates satiety
and that is why it's kind of like a
hormone which prevents more food uptake
and it makes a lot of sense because once
you have
a lot of food inside your stomach and
it's going down in your intestine to be
digested
at that point of time you need to focus
more on digestion rather than ingesting
more food so it
brings out a feeling of satiety and
prevent
more food ingestion now in case of both
humans and
rodents it has been seen that these cck
receptors are present
in limbic system and they have a
um anxiogenic effect so it increase
anxiety or panic now it's not really
known
the detail function is not really known
and yet to be discovered
so so far we have learned quite a lot of
functions and molecular mechanisms by
which
cholecystokinin works and a
comprehensive summary
is given in this table you can take a
screenshot of it it could be a
nice flash card for your preparation so
as per summary we can say that
cholecystokinin has
widespread effect on stomach gallbladder
pancreas
and even brain so all this thing
makes cholecystokinin a very important
local hormone for digestion and
[Music]
absorption so i hope that
this video was comprehensive if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
you can help me in patreon
by being a patreon and contributing five
dollars only
and my courses are also available in an
academy you can use my code
ap 10 to get a 10 discount on that see
you in the next video
thank you and do let me know in the
comment how you like my videos thank you
guys